okay so you bring up some of what's
going on with the prison system in the
UK you've been to prison a couple times
actually I think about two weeks ago you
might have been in prison for a day or
something is that right
I'm almost arrested up in arrested and
charged again yes yeah so I don't want
to get too much into the things that
you've been arrested for some of them
sound like extremely chumped trumped-up
charges this is a lot of what your book
is about but can you talk a little bit
about what your experience was like in
prison and how powerful the ideas of
Islamism are actually spreading in the
prison system so from the first time I
went to custody in 2004 2005 things have
moved forward very quickly within the
prison system so when - when I then the
next time that I went back into prison
was 2010 for actually illegally entering
and - in America but that was in 2010
and what I've witnessed each time I've
been in custody would terrify anyone and
I honestly say that if you could see the
maximum-security prisons that with the
most dangerous prisoners and most
dangerous men in the UK are being used
as Isis training camps there Isis
training camps the white lads the black
lads every one is converting everyone
has a big huge beard it is the biggest
gang in the system and it's something
that the authorities have not got grip
off they can't control the Imams god
bless them some of them are are trying
but they're seen as studious - so the
Imams people are not taking their
Shahada and converting to Islam in the
mosque on Friday they're they're doing
on the wing on the prisoners wings they
run their own mosques right I know so
this is going to sound sort of
amateurish because I've never been to
prison but when you've been there what
like how is it that these ideas spread
why is it that the prison system is
allowing now I know this this is in the
United States - with okay there's all
kinds of crazy religious stuff that goes
on in prisons and drug deals and all you
know it's all nuts but what is going on
that that they're even allowing these
ideas to spread I can't stop them I
can't stop them
and it's it's a Islam forms of
brotherhood stray away a Brotherhood
you messed with one Muslim you mess with
every Muslim so in some instances Islam
is being used within the prison system
use for power control money it's
something that anyone can attach
themselves to in it and that's what's
happened but it's also been orchestrated
and organized too you seen in British
prisons where if a Muslim gets another a
non-muslim to convert outside sources
are sending them in money yeah and also
if you know the ideology of Islam it's
the pathway to heaven for them
it's the pathway to heaven is to spread
Islam to spread our and to convert
prisoners but what you're seeing then is
some of the most dangerous and extreme
people in the UK are converting to Islam
and it also gives when I say it's
powerful we look in the UK we've lost
our identity through political
correctness and through years and years
have been beaten down English people
have lost their community we don't have
the community feeling that others that
Muslim community have and when you've
lost your identity in your tour time and
time again or you're told time and time
again that your identity in your culture
and your history is not good and then
and then comes along this this powerful
powerful community that will stick
together and we and you'll never be on
your own and it gives them everything
they've been searching for we have to
remember a lot of people who are in the
prison system have been wronged their
whole life from a very young age they've
done a lot of wrong as well but there's
a reason many of them have chose that
path they've started with nothing that
had nothing in they've got nothing Islam
gives them a cause it gives them
something something to fight for
gives them something to concentrate on
it and and I can though I've I've seen a
lot in my life but what I saw happening
in the prison system I don't know how
we're going to deal with it well I do
know think steps we can take if you if
you look at the statistics in French
prisons I have a population of I believe
7 percent Muslim 70 percent of the
prisoners are Muslim in the UK I spoke
to prison officers who said that in one
week they had 60 conversions because a
Muslim gang had come into the prison and
just started beating an attack in
everybody to convert and then before you
know it everyone just converts further
for the easy time because if you're in
trouble when you want protection you
convert so when
were in jail speaking of being beaten
you were beaten basically to a pulp
right I mean all your teeth knocked out
and really some horrible stuff but you
never converted so how did you even or I
guess just talk about the violence that
you were subjected to first so I was in
the UK prison system they have laws and
rules that they have to follow they have
a duty of care for every prisoner now
what they did went against every single
war so I'm under no doubt in fact in
fact if I talk when I was taken to wood
Hill wood here was a maximum-security
prison in the UK the houses some of the
country's most feared and dangerous
terrorists I was in prison for a
financial irregularities Anu I was taken
to a maximum security category a prison
I was put on put putting in my sarin the
very first day when my door first opened
it was an ex-world Marine Commando who's
a priest in the British military and he
said when they come to get you from this
cell do not leave this cell know and
what he goes your life depends on it
don't leave this cell and then ten
minutes later he's come with two other
prison officers and said come on you're
going to be weak obviously I said I'm
not going anywhere
I'm not only I'm not leaving this cell
yeah because I didn't leave the cell
then get arrested so I'll get a further
charge I'm arrested and then and then
I'll go to see Melissa at the next day
and I have a meeting with my solicitor
about what's happening when they take me
back after the meet and they open up a
waiting room and as soon as I look in
the waiting room I see the big huge
beard of a white white convert I'm put
into the room of about eight people in
it and I'm violently attacked and and
the doors locked
the door was locked by the prison
officers the door was locked and I'm
left to be bit violently being and then
not just that but I was arrested again
for fine they said but but that's just
one experience in the prison system to
be honest I'm lucky and I believe that
people were pulling strings in order to
have me killed and I think even there
they are scratching their heads to how I
walked out and that's just one
experience that's happened time and time
my you said I spent a day the other week
him in custody again yeah this was this
was quite recent just probably six
months ago I was coming to the end
my license period with the afar ease
where they have you on a control order I
wasn't allowed to contact people who are
in the organisation I used to used to
and this was for a mortgage a so-called
mortgage forward here anyone who reads
my reads did that anyone who reads the
story of what happened will see what it
was all about but I was um I was taken
from last eight days so last eight days
I was put back in prison I was taken to
a brick a prison called Peter Brock
where I said at the star since I've got
the other self off eight days left
eight days I'm gonna get killed yeah
just put me and put me in isolation it I
don't care if you don't open the door
five days you know and then eight days
let me go home I've come out of my cell
and I've told a prison officer again I
said look we know what's going to happen
here and they said I will have a word
and then a prisoner has come up to me
what an English prisoner and he put his
hand over his mouth he said you're going
to get done with boiling war now in
prison in prison they put boiling water
of sugar and it takes you it will take
your face off
so I'm looking I've got two minutes to
think I said who's going to do it and he
said the lad behind the door has put the
money up because he'd paid money to have
me her now the lab behind the standing
next door was doing 28 years in prison
for a murder where they cut a man's nose
off the guy's ears off they killed him
now
there was four of them in for that
murder I'm in for eight days I am known
as someone who has I've had a al-shabaab
of named me to be killed
I've had six government Osman warnings
saying that there's intelligence I'm
going to be murdered by Muslims and Here
I am doing eight days house with Muslim
murderers
and then I'm saw more Minds going quick
I already know that I've asked the
prison authorities to segregate me so
there's no luck there I look across and
I do what I had to do and right before
he has a chance to turn around with his
cup I strike him and then and then the
prison all over screws the prison
officers come and jump in now I went
before the prison governor for that
offense where I explained myself I said
look we you put me in this position or
where I have to defend myself they
decided to take no further action I was
then I was released from prison or then
went on a holiday with my wife and
children I landed back at home at Luton
Airport at midnight and the
lissa way of me they arrested me in
front of my kids and they arrested me
for that for attacking the Somalian
prisoner who was going to do me with
boiling water they then made a decision
in October last year to no further
action so they said we're not taking any
further action I then recently just two
weeks ago I launched a buggy to UK which
is a new organization to have street
demonstrations and two days later they
come and they come Andrea rest in me for
the offense that they'd already dropped
yeah I mean this is a lot of what your
book is about and it's sort of this
endless cycle that you you've been part
of and I know we could talk about the
prison stuff forever because you're just
scratching the surface of it but let's
talk about pegida a little bit so I
think you just got back from Germany you
were doing something with them in
Germany is that right back yeah I just
got back last night so I went to
Copenhagen first where I bought British
journalist with us so we went to
Copenhagen put to a sort of launched
buggy des in Denmark and to ask the
people to stand with us on the 6th of
February because on the 6th of February
we're planning demonstrations in 14
countries now this is the first time a
coalition like this has been formed and
it's only been made possible by the P by
the commitment and the people of Dresden
and their leadership of looks Backman
and and the other the others interested
because for the last year every single
Monday for 53 weeks they have taken to
the streets in their tens of thousands
of times
I thought the demonstration I just went
through this Monday there was well over
10 to 15 thousand people there in a
completely peaceful civilized manner to
express their their concern free passive
resistance or what's happening so just
to be clear when when this this mass
attack happened in Cologne just a couple
weeks ago at the beginning of the year
it seemed like the police were not there
people did not know who to turn to
women were literally were being raped
and attacked and all of that stuff and
then there were some demonstrations a
couple days later I think in Cologne in
some other cities and suddenly there
were a lot of police to police the
people that were there to protest the
violence that happened to the women so I
said really backwards here I was there
at that demonstration I know exactly
what it is when when you get large
disturbances of Muslims the police do
stay away they because if they go in
with their battens if they go in and try
and police the streets they'll provoke a
riot and that riot will spread and they
know that so that we've seen that many
times lockers are when we hang up here I
can send you video after video which
actually shows the police running away
in the UK now they don't run away from
us they'd knock your teeth out knock
your head off before they run away when
it comes that they're told to police the
communities differently now on New
Year's Eve the head of the police
actually asks his superiors he asks for
an extra hundred police officers he was
refused yeah and then and then what we
saw was these mass attacks and these
mass rapes of German women and you're
right they had no one to turn to and I
traveled out there for the next
demonstration and lo and behold you've
got thousands of police officers you've
got water cannons and then German people
were attacked with water cannons by the
police so is the situation in Germany
particularly precarious even though you
mostly focus in the UK because that's
where you're from I've heard a lot of
people say that in Germany because of
the guilt related to the Holocaust that
they feel as a nation a certain amount
of guilt
so when when these migrants and all
these people want to come there they
feel an extra need to help them and
because of that that's why Merkel let in
the whatever it is I think it's 1.2
million people and that even when they
do violent acts as a society they're
more condoning of it because they know
that their ancestors have done some
pretty horrible stuff well this
generation of Germans seem to be living
with a and suffering from guilt from
Hitler yeah the net generation of
Germans will suffer and live with guilt
from Angela Merkel so that's what I need
to wake up to you and this generation
have nothing to feel guilty about they
have a beautiful country a beautiful
culture the envy of the world
they're beautiful people beautiful such
civilizing decent people and they have
nothing to feel guilty of so and
what-what this is in that is
underestimation of the culture and
ideology they're allowing it that's what
it is like everyone's all make you human
responses we must help these people but
not help them if it involves the
destruction of your culture and your and
your country not help them at the cost
or the expense of young German girls but
and I'm all for helping refugees I just
don't think they should be helped in
Europe I think they should be helped in
the Middle East I think that we should
be leading the way in funding and
military support to make sure that there
are buffer zones but I don't think that
important and to be honest by important
1.2 million ich is she making any
impacts on the suffering of refugees
across the Middle East because there's
tens of millions yeah and what whatever
option is there Bri bring the whole of
Syria into Europe it solves nothing
it solves nothing and what she's
actually done by doing this is she's
open up the floodgates and will now see
absolute stampedes of tens of millions
over the next five years well I've also
read a bunch on how it's not just about
the violence but also just the actual
system the systems that are in place the
social systems you know I was reading
something this morning about how all of
these people that are coming from Syria
they all a huge percent of them have
really bad teeth their teeth are really
bad now they're going to get free dental
coverage and it's going to cost some
nicely with something like a billion
euros or something but they're not going
to pay for it so the average German
taxpayer is going to have have to pay
for it and then that right there when
their taxes go up then naturally they're
going to be more resentful of these
people so it's it's hitting people in
the at the economic level and at the
violent level it just seems like a
terrible mix it's kind of a society it's
going to hit them everywhere
I believe ie percent of them can't read
or write I believe that many of the real
refugees have come from Syria are going
to be suffering from PTSD post-traumatic
stress stress disorder and they're going
to need counseling they're going to need
help there's so many problems that will
come from this yeah and we say 1.2
million but they're allowed to bring
their families after three years right
and they're that and they're allowed
their EU passports so that 1.2 will
become 6 or eh it doesn't have the
infrastructure simply but what Angela
Merkel is fully aware of is that they
won't stay in Germany they're gonna come
to countries like mine yeah she knows
she knows and in fact just last week
though the German government have come
out and said we've lost 600,000 refugees
we've lost them
seekers we've lost them they're not
where they said they were they're gone
now
600,000 how many of them are rapists how
many are Isis fighters how many are
criminals we have no idea no idea at all
so let me ask you this because a lot of
this you know at some level you hear the
people throwing around the term Trojan
horse a lot and a lot of it sort of
sounds like a conspiracy that there has
been this organized effort to just
influx all these people and I think I've
seen even in some of the videos that
you've tweeted when you see just like
hundreds or thousands of migrants
crossing it does seem like it's 80 or
90% men men that are 20 or 30 it you
don't see a lot of women you see
occasionally you'll see some women and
some children but it does seem like a
lot of men but to go that route it
sounds like a conspiracy theory to go
and say oh this is there's an
intentional plan to flood Europe with
these people to ultimately take over but
I suspect by the 50 minutes we've spent
together you don't think it's much of a
conspiracy mmm that can't be know of a
reason anyone with any common sense and
intelligence or brain can can look at
what's happening and know it's not going
to be good for Europe well anyone can
look at what's happening Angela Merkel
made comment such as immigrants are more
prone to violence and extremism than the
non immigrants she said that years ago
she's also made comments saying that
multiculturalism has failed she they've
already failed to integrate millions of
Muslims there so why is she bringing
millions more what reason are if anyone
can help scan give a reason and how are
these millions well what do you think
what do you think actually what do you
think is going on in her head then we if
everything you've said here is true
Angela Merkel she was just time woman of
the year right I mean this is a this is
a bright lady right so what a math class
by children Angela Merkel has no
children and she cares not for the
future of our country or our people
that's truthfully what I feel I don't
think she cares about about the future
of her people and at the same time you
have this this as you said people
holding her up on a pedestal at first at
first wherever it was through Immelt
I can't say it was through ill intention
because I think they know they everyone
knows full well what this is going to do
to Europe when we know full well what's
going to happen and what you're seeing
is actually the only countries in Europe
that are freely speed
in honestly are the countries that don't
have a rather high percentage of Muslims
its Poland its Hungary its Czech
Republic its Slovakia their political
leaders are coming out and saying what
needs to be said now if you look at the
UK's former political leaders if you
look at Sir William Gladstone he held
the Koran above his head he's in
Parliament and he said that Islam this
this Quran is a violent and a cursed
book and will never be have peace on
this earth so long as we have this book
Winston Churchill said that individual
Muslims will show amazing
characteristics but the the backwardness
of Islam has the power to bring Europe
back to the dark ages now there are two
world leaders we have statues on that
the whole world loves and if they were
around today they will be called bigots
and extremists and that's simply for
telling the truth my prime minister
my prime minister says that Islam is a
religion of peace and the facts speak
very different to that and at the moment
the problem we have is that by telling
the truth which even if people don't
like the truth we have to be honest I
also think when people say Islam is a
religion of peace or Christian that is
originally peace or Judaism is a
religion of peace it's a moot point a
religion is because a religion is only a
set of ideas all the religion is is what
its adherents do right it's a religion
of peace that that means nothing that an
idea is what people do with it
so I find those statements like that
just don't add anything to the
conversation no and we hear them after
every terrorist attack every single
terrorist so that's what we that's what
we talked and in fact it's not all we
told about I'll give you two other
circumstances now as a parent has it
that I was studying the biography of
Mohammed yeah and I'm sad I'm and I'm
preparing for a debate and my daughter
who is eight years old she walked past
me and said because I don't I never
taught my children a thing my kids never
heard of the English Defence League yeah
I I have I live two very separate lives
and I want to protect them for as long
as possible from understanding these
politics my daughter walked past and
said Muhammad peace be upon him and I
looked her and I said what did you just
say and why did you just say that and
she said well as tall as school you have
to say peace be upon him
I said peace be upon him and then and
that source is one instant then in that
another instant that about a mosque and
then when I took my children to look at
another school and one of the things
that one of the things they had to do
was put the different religious
buildings with the differently just
words yeah
the only one my daughter could do the
religions of the world was Islam because
what's happening now in the National
Curriculum in the UK is that Islam is
the favorite religion Islam is what's
being pushed and propagated to all of
our youthful children and their
brainwashing I don't mind if they want
to talk about Mohammed tell the truth
yeah tell us about the man he was not a
man of peace some of the things he done
was some sort such immoral things no he
killed a lot of people there's no no
thing that's a fact it's a fact but they
not teaching there they're teaching that
this is this great man this great man
Muhammad that we must all respect and
say peace be upon him that's what
they're teaching eight-year-old English
children so then by the time that next
generation come out of the schools
they've been brainwashed into this
mindset and and as soon as your parents
even I've seen it across the country
parents who have not not wanted their
children to be taught these things and
then branded as racist as well I'm all
for the truth being talked to my kids
but then I on that then haven't even
spoke to my children if I haven't spoke
to my children about Islam I want all
one's for talking to about well that's
one of the strange things and I think we
see this a little bit in America where
they'll say well we need to learn more
about Islam because of this and to me
it's like we should not be learning more
about Islam we should not be learning
more about Christianity we should not be
learning more about Judaism or Mormonism
or Jainism or any of them what we should
be learning about our secular values we
should be learning about the things that
tie us together not all the little
differences that are just going to split
us I'm completely in agreement it's just
a fundamental problem or I always say
that I believe in secular schools I
think we have secular schools but then I
don't believe we should also I don't
believe that should pose pose a problem
for seek to for seek schools or induce
school or Christian schools because
because they're not causing us the
problems that we face these huge
problems that we face currently are
caused by Islam they're inspired by
Islam and if they want to sit in schools
and talk about Muhammad they need to
tell them that
he raped a child he married a child he
committed murder that they need to tell
the truth and they're not so then we
have this complete watered-down
educational system there is line to the
next generation of youth in the UK yeah
all right well we have to wrap up I feel
like there's so much more we could talk
about and and hopefully with the way I
preface this whole episode people will
learn about you and they can make the
decisions you know whether they think
you're racist or whether they they think
you're you're preaching the truth or
somewhere in between but just to wrap up
give me something that you think give me
some hope here give me some hope I mean
you're working with pagina now doesn't
sound like a hate organization to me so
give me some hope for an ability to turn
some of this around and for some
coexistence
Europe is waking it up hugely the people
of Europe you've just seen a declaration
called the fortress Europe which is a
it's called the product declaration
which 14 different countries now have
assigned to on the 6th of February for
the first time there's going to be
demonstrations in England in Holland in
Denmark in Germany in the Czech Republic
in Poland all simultaneously at the same
time this is the star of a friendship
and partnerships being built across
Europe not just Europe actually
Australia also marching with us we hope
that by the next time we have America we
have we have Canada we have India we
have the world because this is a
worldwide problem we have to face and
then yeah there is hope and then always
be hope because it to be honest I know
how hardly that our love for freedom and
our love for democracy will always
outweigh their their their hatred and
walk for Sharia yeah all right well
listen it was really interesting talking
to you and I'm sure we'll keep talking
but I was going to send people to Amazon
to buy your book but Amazon took your
book off didn't they they took it off
and put it back up three times right so
I'm not sure if it's up right now but
they can definitely get your book at
Tommy Robinson dot Co UK and they can
get the Kindle version at least Indo in
America yeah on Amazon yeah all right
well it was a pleasure talking to you
and you know it's difficult stuff but
that's why we have to have these
conversations so I thank you for coming
on
[Music]